we have a lot of activity going on at
Harvard at the present time but it's
hard to judge how many people are
employed full-time or part-time by the
encyclopedia project we anticipate we'll
be able to draw down about 30 million
from grants that are mainly from the
MacArthur um but I looking ahead a bit I
would say maybe if you if you want a
round figure I'd say about a hundred
people are a full-time or a large part
of part time and I would expect that to
expand as funding becomes available and
we really get onto the logarithmic stay
on essays you know of the doing the
mapping of the world but I would expect
that probably eventually a couple of
thousand it'll be a big science project
but I don't think it will compare in any
way in dollars spent to most of our
major space program it probably would be
comparable to what was spent for the
human genome project in ultimately it
would be a couple of billion dollars
you